the typical Shanker is raised indurated
sharply circumscribed frequently
ulcerated usually has satellite buboes
and is not particularly painful unless
there is secondary infection Schenker's
frequently are not typical and maybe
multiple suspect any genital lesion in
every case of urethral discharge palpate
the urethra for possible entry urethral
Shanker follow every case of gonorrhea
with blood tests for four months to rule
out syphilis look for cervical
Schenker's they occur some are our
typical consisting merely of diffuse
enlargement and in duration of the
entire cervix extra genital Shanker's
occur on the lip tonsil breast and
elsewhere do dark fields on suspicion
and blood tests routinely look for
Schenker of the finger in doctors and
nurses they are painful and often not as
typical as this one they frequently
resemble an ordinary paronychia this
lesion and those following are not
syphilitic darkfield examination should
be performed on every genital lesion and
on all suspected extra genital lesions
if repeated dark fields are negative
follow with blood tests for four months
to rule out syphilis take a blood test
at least once a week for the first two
months and once a month for the next two
months
differential diagnosis of primary
syphilis depends largely upon darkfield
examination to prepare the lesion for
obtaining a specimen soak a piece of
gauze in normal saline solution and rub
hard to produce slight abrasion after
the surface of the lesion has been
cleansed and abraded blot it with a dry
piece of gauze and wait a few seconds
for serum to use from the surface now
touch a clean dry slide to the serum and
cover specimen with a clean dry cover
slip the specimen is now ready to be
placed under the dark field microscope
for examination spirochete a paladin
resembles many non-pathogenic sterile
therefore darkfield examination should
be undertaken only by one who is
thoroughly experienced in this procedure
in localities where persons experienced
in dark field technique are not
available they delayed dark field
technique is useful the specimen of
serum is drawn into a capillary tube the
ends sealed and the tube mailed
immediately most state health
department's provide for examination of
delayed dark field specimens do not use
darkfield examination for lesions inside
the mouth unless the specimen is taken
by aspiration rather than from the
surface of the lesion some normal mouths
spirochetes cannot be distinguished from
spirochete a paladin if the lesion is on
the outer surface of the lip cleanse the
surface carefully before taking the
specimen specimens may also be obtained
by aspiration of serum from the base of
a lesion one-tenth CC of normal saline
is injected and withdrawn a single
negative darkfield examination does not
exclude syphilis Schenker's are apt to
be dark field negative if topical
applications have been used if the
patient has received antisyphilis serum
treatment of any kind or if the lesion
has been present more than a month or
six weeks at least three or four
negative specimens should be obtained
before a suspected lesion is considered
darkfield negative on the other hand a
positive dark field establishes the
diagnosis of syphilis even while the
blood test is still negative time is of
the essence in the diagnosis of syphilis
let us assume an exposure to syphilis or
gonorrhea or both at this point in 3 to
6 days there may be evidence of
gonorrhea
both smears and cultures should be made
as early as 10 days after exposure the
chancre may appear it usually develops
in about 21 days although its appearance
may be delayed as long as 3 months a
dark field examination should be
employed a negative dark field of course
does not exclude syphilis from 6 to 9
weeks after exposure the blood test may
be expected to assume diagnostic
significance again a single negative
should not be relied upon the case
should be followed for at least four
months before concluding that infection
has not resulted from the exposure they
control of early syphilis and the
prevention of congenital syphilis and
late manifestations depend on careful
and painstaking attention to the time
element and on a high index of suspicion
during the secondary stage of syphilis
the organism is disseminated throughout
the body this gives rise to a
constitutional reaction with general
malaise and aching of the bones and
joints sore throat may be prominent
there is usually a generalized
lymphadenopathy macular syphilis are
salmon or rose-colored
if natural daylight cannot be used the
light from a blue bulb will often reveal
a macular rash which would be invisible
in light from an ordinary bulb
involvement of the palms and soles is
particularly suggestive secondary
syphilis are often popular
annular lesion should always suggest
syphilis to the physician they
frequently coalesce and assume a surfeit
genus appearance it is not uncommon for
the hair to fall out in patches giving
it a moth-eaten appearance mucus patches
occur in the mouth or nose or on the
genitalia they are usually about 1/2 to
2 centimeters in diameter sharply
circumscribed pink and slightly raised
from the surrounding surface ordinarily
they are not painful moist papules also
known as condylomata occur on moist
contiguous surfaces of the skin they are
raised from the surrounding surface and
around and flat on top venereal warts
are not syphilitic lesions they differ
from moist papules in that they are flat
on the sides rather than on top the
slick papules shown here are large but
often they are so small as to be
overlooked easily split papules may be
the only sign of secondary syphilis
darkfield examination is positive in
cases of iritis the physician should
think first of atropine and second of a
blood test many cases are due to
secondary syphilis these symptoms and
signs of early meningeal neurosyphilis
are those of any acute meningitis this
condition is distinguished by the
positive spinal fluid serologic test for
syphilis it often follows a lapse in
treatment for early syphilis and in such
cases is called neuro recurrence
darkfield examination is useful in
secondary syphilis as well as in primary
syphilis a diagnosis of primary or
secondary syphilis should always be
confirmed either by positive darkfield
or positive blood tests to obtain a
specimen for blood test a tourniquet is
first applied to the upper arm if the
veins are not prominent one is located
by palpation the overlying skin is
cleansed with alcohol the operator's
left thumb draws the skin taut and the
needle is inserted through the skin at
an acute angle and lured until almost
parallel with the vein
the vein is entered and blood withdrawn
the blood is placed in a clean dry test
tube
the tube is Stoppard with a clean dry
cork carefully labeled and prepared for
mailing do not use soap to clean test
tubes for this purpose any residual of
soap will cause hemolysis of the blood
congenital syphilis is transmitted from
mother to fetus in neutral usually about
the fifth month of pregnancy frequently
the fetus dies and a miscarriage or
stillbirth results the infant with
active early congenital syphilis tis
fretful and often has snuffles trusted
lesions about the mouth and nose are
frequently observed there may be a
generalized eruption and moist papules
about the anus and genitalia the
diagnosis should be confirmed by
darkfield examination of the lesions or
by blood tests or by both apparently
well babies are both treated and
untreated syphilitic mothers should be
followed for at least two years perform
blood tests at monthly intervals for six
months and every six months thereafter
in the absence of other evidence a
diagnosis of syphilis should not be made
on the basis of positive blood tests
taken when the child is less than two
months old
unless quantitative tests reveal a
rising titer congenital syphilis can be
prevented by treating infected mothers
but first the infected mothers must be
found take a blood test as soon as
pregnancy is suspected repeat at least
once later in pregnancy take a blood
test as a routine part of physical
examinations before marriage more than
half of the cases of syphilis so
discovered will have been unsuspected
blood tests before marriage
are the particular responsibilities of
the private physician to whom most
couples go the blood tests experienced
impresses itself on the minds of the
young people if it is accompanied by a
physical examination and if the full
significance of the procedure is brought
home to the couple an important
relationship is established with the
physician
later when pregnancy occurs the
physician is afforded the opportunity
not only to meet the threat of
congenital syphilis but also to provide
general prenatal care
thus the private practitioner plays a
vital and fundamental part in both
medical and epidemiologic aspects of
syphilis control personalized education
by him vitalizes the mass program of the
health department every case of syphilis
comes from another case to break this
chain of infection all contacts whether
familial or non familial should be
examined by the physician or for him by
the health department
prostitution is another infant link in
the chain of infection physicians can
help to break this link by demanding
that law enforcement officers vigorously
enforce all laws prohibiting
prostitution procurement solicitation
and assignation periodic examination of
prostitutes does not [__] the spread
of venereal diseases and it involves the
physician as an accessory to the fact
nothing short of total war on Vice will
break this link in the chain of
infection to keep abreast of current
developments in the diagnosis treatment
and public health aspects of syphilis
read venereal disease information one of
the medical journals published by the
United States Public Health Service